-Guys, yesterday we launched
something very cool,
something that's never been done
with a late-night show.
We took "The Tonight Show"
out of the real world
and brought it into "Fortnite."
Yeah, we partnered up with
Samsung to do this.
We wanted to do it right.
So with the help of Samsung
Galaxy's devices, we created
Rockefeller Center, the 30 Rock
building, our studio, studio 6B,
and we built it all
in "Fortnite."
It is called "Tonight at the
Rock Powered by Samsung Galaxy."
And the attention to detail is
mind-blowing.
It's like you're right there --
Look. Isn't this wild?
You can walk around.
You can explore stuff.
But there's also a bunch of
minigames in there you can play.
There's an escape room.
There's a taxi race.
You can play them all with the
help of a Galaxy Z Fold4,
Watch5, Buds2 Pro,
and Tab S8 Ultra.
Anyway, I thought it would be
fun to play one of
the "Fortnite" games
in real life.
So, earlier today I got together
with one of
the most famous gamers
in the world, Bugha.
And we took one of
our "Fortnite" minigames
into the real world.
Check it out.
-Hey, everybody.
I'm Jimmy Fallon.
I'm here with "Fortnite"
World Cup champion Bugha,
and we're about to play a game
of giant pong which you can find
on the new "Tonight Show
Tonight at the Rock" experience
on "Fortnite." But first,
we need some practice.
Let's go. Is that you?
Dorfdad running behind me?
What are you doing behind me?
Stop doing that.
How do we play giant pong?
-Right on this portal.
-Yep.
-Then we hop on. Boom.
-Alright.
We each get 10 seconds here.
That's your first shot.
-It happens. It happens.
-Ooh, this one has potential!
Are you kidding me?
How is that even possible to
just lay on the side of a cup?
Did I get it?
Oh, yeah, powerup!
Galaxy Watch5 GPS powerup.
Alright, I'm going to give you
the win on that.
But how about we go play
giant pong in real life?
-Let's do it.
-We are on the roof garden here
at Rockefeller Center, and Bugha
and I are about to compete
in real life giant pong.
We each have 10 balls.
If you get one in the cup,
it's one point.
We also created our own
real-life Galaxy powerup ring.
If you get it through there,
it's two points.
Let's do this.
Bugha, you're up. Are you going
for the cup or the two points?
-I'm going for the cup.
-Okay.
-What?
-I'll show you how to do it.
Like this.
[ Laughter ]
Oh! Just like that.
Ooh, 1-1.
[ Cheers and applause ]
You can miss this one.
Don't worry about it.
You can relax.
You can relax!
I got to go for two.
-There it is.
There it is.
[ Laughter ]
-Hashtag, help me here.
Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Distract him.
-He's contesting the shot.
-Oh! How?
I can't beat this guy.
The champion, Bugha!
[ Cheers and applause ]
You're the giant pong champ.
Congratulations, buddy.
-Thank you.
-But unfortunately, the only
replay we can show is this one.
-There it is.
-There you go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
My thanks -- It is so cool.
It's really fun to play.
My thanks to Samsung,
"Fortnite,"
and Bugha for doing that.
"Tonight at the Rock
Powered by Samsung Galaxy"
is available now.
Scan this QR code right now.
I know you've got your phones
on you.
Or you can go to
tonightshow.com/
tonightattherock.
It's really fun, everybody.
Check it out.